also mich hat oder mich bewegt 40
prozent der wahlberechtigten sind über
60 jahre alt 14 prozent sind unter 30
und für mich ist eine frage der
generationengerechtigkeit dass wir das
wahlalter jetzt mal auf 16 jahre
absenken das wären 1,5 millionen mehr
wahlberechtigte und um mal gleich die
vier argumente zu entkräften die dann
immer kommen erstens können die das denn
schon ja die können das denn in vier
bundesländern dürfen sie schon den
landtagswahlen wählen mit 16 in elf
bundesländern in den kommunalwahlen also
warum nicht auch im bund zweitens geht
das überhaupt oder müssen wir da nicht
artikel 38 des grundgesetzes ändern ja
geht haben wir schon mal geändert in den
70er jahren haben wir das wahlrecht von
21 auf 18 gesenkt geht also auch
drittens machen das nur wie oder macht
das noch irgendwer anders österreich wo
ich gestern war das konservative
österreich hat das 2017 eingeführt das
wahlrecht mit 16 und es steht noch und
insofern mein plädoyer
es sind eh schon alle dafür außer cdu
fdp freien wir das jetzt in den
koalitionsvertrag und setzen das um aus
meiner sicht gibt es kein besseres
instrument um mal ein bisschen chancen
und generationengerechtigkeit hier in
deutschland zu etablieren
also meine größte sorge bei dieser
forderung war bisher dass dann alle
losgehen und die grünen wählen aber das
ist nach den wahlergebnissen sich jetzt
gesehen hat und den statistiken ja auch
entkräftet das etwas was mich an dieser
wahl immer noch mit der reiseweg prozent
23 prozent der erst- wähler fdp 22
prozent der unter 25-jährigen fdp man
hat uns über monate über talkshows habt
ihr euch gerade ich will nicht sagen
gestritten intensiv ausgetauscht man hat
uns über monate den eindruck vermittelt
die jungen leute wählen die grünen weil
das sind die einzigen die sich um das
klima kümmern und wir sehen wenn wir auf
die ergebnisse gucken nichts daran hat
bestimmt es gibt ein total
differenziertes bild und ich finde
tatsächlich dass das ein sehr gutes
argument ist das wahlrecht für für unter
18-jährige zu ermöglichen mir würde sich
eher die frage stellen wenn ich dieses
heiligste recht bekomme welche pflichten
gehen damit einher die wir vielleicht
auch absenken müssten auch aber auch
solche für nicht einher wählen zu gehen
und wenn du der anguckt was in brand
passiert da dürfen sie im land in den
landtagswahlen wählen ist es die
stärkste wahlbeteiligung bei den 16 bis
18 stärker als bei den 18 bis 20
jährigen also politische bildung müssen
wir in den schulen etablieren das fängt
aber evi früher an weil wir es ja bei
den 18 jährigen bisher auch versäumen
also für mich kein argument zu sagen die
16 jährigen wählen ja nur was ihre
eltern wählen dass kunden gedacht sind
dann auch also ich würde dich total
unterstützen wollen weil gerade heute
ist die politische jugend oder die
jugend so politisch wie noch nie oder
schon lange nicht mehr die setzen sich
sehr detailliert mit den ganzen
politischen themen auseinander und seien
wir ehrlich wir haben heute eine
schuldenlast die daher auf den künftigen
generationen lastet die so hoch ist dass
sämtliche spielräume auch weggenommen
werden also warum lassen wir nicht
endlich die jugend mit entscheiden warum
trauen wenig auch den ein bisschen
verantwortung weil es ist jetzt was die
pflicht der ampel ja weil du hast drei
parteien die sind dafür also das muss im
nebel die koalition rasch ein auch ab 16
machen als das führerscheinalter auch
untersätzen für mich eine andere
diskussion weil hier geht es darum dass
wir mehr politik für die zukunft machen
da mal wieder in zukunft mehr politik
für das lange die lange perspektive und
weniger opportunistisch kurze wie viel
rente kriege ich jetzt gerade und
deswegen ist das für mich einfach so was
wenn das jetzt nicht im
koalitionsvertrag steht dann kann man da
gleich den nächsten hashtag irgendwie
wahlalter runter zukunft drauf oder so
laut sie mir nicht sicher ob die grünen
noch so engagiert dafür sind wie sie
gerade erst ja ja immer aber im mai
tasten sie alle erst wählerwillen die
grünen es ist natürlich eine
scheindebatte das muss man ganz klar
sagen diese zwei jahre machen erstens
den kohl nicht fett weiters müsste man
mit dem aktiven wahlrecht auch das
passive des gewählt werden es ab senken
wollen wir tatsächlich dass man ab 16 im
bundestag gewählt werden kann man kann
man ja wollen kann man wollen aber es
ist aber was schwer aber ich überlege
jetzt gerade bin ja geneigt ja immer
zuzustimmen deswegen muss sich jetzt
kurz überlegen aber ich habe eigentlich
man wenn jemand mit 16 gewählt wird kein
problem damit wenn da in den bundestag
ein warum nicht mit 14 also woran machen
wir na ja wir machen ja als gesellschaft
und das wird ja wie man immer so schön
sagt wird ja immer wieder neu verhandelt
tatsächlich loten wir immer wieder aus
wo sind grenzen wo verläuft vielleicht
die grenze aus mitverantwortung
übernehmen
welche rechte habe ich schon wie wirkt
sich das aus eben auch mögliches
mandatsträger schafft und da würde ich
tatsächlich sagen so wie wir mal von 21
auf 18 gegangen sind die 68er revolution
übrigens dann kann man ein sehr feines
verfügt jahre und alle wir sehen uns ja
einig das ist eine willkürliche grenze
ist die man irgendwo zieht und die man
auch biologisch nicht begründen kann
darum finde ich durch in dem bereich
sind desto strafe mit 16 das dann
richtig moment mache ist das ist alles
juristisch nicht als juristischer
biologisch könnte man nicht an
einschätzen warum man mit 16 irgendwie
anders strukturiert ist als mit 18 da
der wagen offen sagen 25 grad ein auto
alleine also man kann dann zwar über die
regierung mitbestimmen aber noch kein
auto führen dafür ist man noch zu unreif
finde ich nicht wirklich logisch dass
aber das was mich stört ist das
kernargument dass eine gruppe zu wenig
wählt bei den jungen und zu viele alte
wenn wir so anfangen dann können wir
irgendwann den alten das wählen
verbieten und die demografen häufig bei
uns eben leider so dass wir viel zu
wenig kinder kriegen deshalb wird diese
gruppe auch wenn das auf zwölf senken
immer lauter repräsentierten gefährliche
diskussion auch verehrt spielst du die
generationen gegeneinander aus und das
löse das ist dass man etwas kerniger
intel ich finde nicht dass andere
ausspielen sondern gerade in den
parlamenten finden kinder und
jugendthemen viel zu wild und ich finde
wir müssen wenn wir uns jetzt anderthalb
jahre pandemie anschauen dann sehen wir
ganz klar es ist politik für diejenigen
gemacht worden die ich sag jetzt mal
bewusst zu gestützt nur noch sehr wenig
zeit auf dieser erde zu verbringen haben
und diejenigen die vielleicht leben
traumatisiert verbringen werden sind
einfach komplett vergessen und ignoriert
wurde eine widerstandsgeist auch bei den
16 bis 18 jährigen julian also
vielleicht tue ich mich da aber ich habe
die für das klima auf die straße gehen
sehen für ihre freiheiten und es war ja
auch ob manche skurrilen
eine stimme
23 fdp ist ja wahrscheinlich dir spüren
durch das war erzählte jetzt also ich
würde jetzt nicht alles denn die seien
aber ich spüre noch es geht ihm die eine
zahl aber wir spüren doch das war ja
aber wir stehen ja auch dass wahlkämpfe
seit jahrzehnten ausgerichtet sind auf
das thema rente wer am meisten bei der
rente womit ist denn die wahlkarte
gewonnen worden
ländern mit dem thema dem bike das thema
rente vorgaben aber wohl aber ich will
die leute interessiert sind ja aber die
jungen die jetzt gewählt haben wissen
doch dass sie von der rente die olaf
scholz den alten jetzt versprochen
keinen einzigen bekommen 100 milliarden
steuergeld in die rente und es war im
wahlkampf einigkeit dass wir da nicht
angehen dass das rentenalter deutlich
gesteigert wird ja für das auch kein
feiner aktien restaurants wandern ja
nicht faszinieren aber das wird nicht
dadurch behoben dass wir das wahlalter
um zwei jahre untergehen hinzu kommt
dass ausgerechnet die jungen immer die
geringste wahlbeteiligung haben und man
kann das gerne noch absenken man könnte
es aber auch 10 senken wenn es uns
gefällt aber es wird an der politik
nichts ändern und dass nur diejenigen
die betroffen sind dann auch die politik
machen das funktioniert ohnehin meiner
miteinander die man alles nicht die
besseren mittel zur wahrung bäume die zu
kleinen erwachsenen machen also ich muss
sagen ich bin froh dass ich auch meine
team jahre hatte und ich muss sagen wenn
man darüber nachdenkt dass dann 16 im
bundestag wollen sie enger jünger war
eine sind rechts da bist du schon findet
der teilchen wie das heißt es gibt leute
mit 16 die auch schon ihre eigenen in
eigenen lohn und brot sind die haben ihr
eigenes leben und ich finde die jetzt zu
kindern und bewusst die klein zu halten
finde ich und
durchschnittsalter aller zeiten im
bundestag aktuell jetzt also das heißt
einfach die jugend ist anders als ich
bin 42 meine generation hat sich nicht
politisch eingebracht die hätten mit 16
gesagt um gottes willen die heute 16
jährigen wollen also es ist ein an dem
euregio 90 um eine schwester ist 23
findung mit dem altern zu argumentieren
aber so also ich bin ja noch nein ich
will sagen auch durch meine schwestern
im freundeskreis bin ich nah dran ich
finde ich verstehe das argument aktion
da und deswegen fand ich auch meine
frage mein einbruch anfang gar nicht so
doof was mit dem führerschein ist weil
sollen sein bundestagsmandat ab aber
nicht auto fahren dürfen also ich finde
schon und werden dann wieder
zurückzufahren sie sollen wählen und ich
bundestagsmandat in die filme ab 18
nicht rein aber man kann schon mal
wählen das ist ein toller frank naja
wenn man wenn man etwa abgeordneter ist
kann man ja in vereinen weil man genießt
immunität also man kann also zumindest
dafür dass da jetzt sind wir beim
argumenten abschließende frage zu dem
thema was haltet ihr von dem gedanken
familienwahlrecht also meine stimme plus
die stimmen all der
ich bin die gewinnt findet ich wenn
dafür zu eigener mündigkeit zu erziehen
weil viel zu sehr haben wir schon viel
zu lange immer das gewesen was unsere
eltern gewählt haben und ich finde jeder
muss irgendwie ein recht auf eine eigene
meinung haben aber warum also warum
sollte man nicht über seine kinder
mitstimmen dürfen ja wenn man drei war
eine meinung haben aber die können ja
vielleicht drei jahre alt sein
das kommt jetzt auf eine abwandlung sagt
dass dieses fanden aber das eine und das
ist das spannende thema also was ist
damit der dritte die merck stimmt dann
sollten wir aber haben wenn man das noch
weiter denkt ich bin auch dagegen aber
wenn man es noch weiter denkt sollen
auch der der mehr gehalt weil kinder
geben mir dann bonuspunkt beim wahlrecht
soll wenn man das jetzt weiter ausführt
soll denn auch der der mehr gehalt
verdienen mehr stimmen kriegen also
werden dann alle anders also es ist eher
so wie messi gehen wir dann weiter erst
mal mit den kindern beim gehalt dann
geht's jetzt ja jungen generation mehr
jungen generation auch zu bilden nein
abstimmen denkt ich mich bereits das
thema ja nur um zu sagen dass ich das
also ehrlich gesagt familienwahlrecht
schwierig findet weil dann kann man auch
in andere bereiche gehen die
überspitzung was an frau in bonn wirkt
ist schon ganz gut ist ja auch dabei
sollte man bleiben aber immer auf
künftig hat bisher auch ganz gut
funktioniert
[Musik]